Los geht's und herzlich willkommen bei Easy
German Live!
Schön, dass ihr alle dabei seid.
Wir begrüßen euch bei YouTube und bei Facebook
live.
Wir sind heute in Berlin live auf der Straße.
Janusz und ich sind nicht auf der Straße.
Zuerst begrüße ich mal meinen Co-Host des
heutigen Tages: Hallo Janusz!
Hallo Cari!
Wo bist du gerade?
Also ich bin so ungefähr ein Zimmer von dir
entfernt, in der gleichen Wohnung.
Bei uns ist es warm und gemütlich und wir
freuen uns schon auf das Treffen, was uns
(be)vorsteht.
Genau, wir treffen nämlich jetzt virtuell
unseren rasenden Reporter Manuel Salmann.
Hallo Manuel!
Hallo, ihr beiden!
Ich stehe hier mit Rawad an der Kamera und
mir hinter dem Mikrofon vor dem Berliner Ostbahnhof.
Wow.
- Daran könnt ihr schon erkennen: Wir sind
im Osten Berlins und es ist kalt.
Ja, das ist ja toll, Manuel.
Du bist live heute wieder unterwegs.
Letzte, letzten Monat waren wir ja auf dem
Alexanderplatz, jetzt bist du am Ostbahnhof.
Was gibt es denn dort zu sehen heute?
Also im Ostbahnhof selbst gibt es nicht so
viel zu sehen.
Ich bin dort gerade angekommen mit der S-Bahn
und es war sehr viel Baustelle, Konstruktionen,
wie so oft in Berlin.
Aber wir sind auch gar nicht hier, um den
Ostbahnhof zu sehen, sondern um das zu sehen,
was ich jetzt schon aus dem Augenwinkel sehe.
Und ich würde sagen, wir machen uns auf den
Weg und du kannst ja mal erklären, was das
Ziel heute ist.
Alles klar, Manuel.
Dann würde ich sagen, ihr geht los, wir gucken
euch zu.
Also wenn ihr mal in Berlin seid, dann ist
das der Ort, zu dem Manuel jetzt geht, ein
absolutes Highlight.
Es ist die East Side Gallery und das ist das
längste erhaltene Teilstück der Berliner
Mauer.
Ihr kennt vielleicht die Berliner Mauer, sie
hat Berlin geteilt () viele Jahre lang.
Und 1989 wurde sie aufgebrochen und damit
änderte auch die Teilung Deutschlands.
Und wir wollen heute mal gucken, wie die Mauer
heute noch aussieht.
Also, eigentlich ist sie weg, aber an einigen
Stellen steht sie noch.
Und Manuel geht jetzt gleich zu der Stelle,
an der man das größte Stück sieht, und
es ist heute eine Kunstgalerie, das können
wir schon verraten.
Manuel, da ist ganz schön viel Polizei am
Ostbahnhof.
Was ist denn da los?
Du, ich glaube, das gehört einfach zu einem
großen Bahnhof dazu, dass Polizei in der
Nähe ist.
Also hier ist alles ruhig, nicht viel los.
Was ich dir erzählen kann, wenn du etwas
aus meinem Leben hören möchtest, ist, dass
ich in diesem Gebäude, dieses Backsteingebäude,
da war ich vor vielen Jahren mal auf einem
Konzert, vor Corona-Zeiten.
Leider habe ich vergessen, wie die Künstlerin
hieß.
Ich war nämlich nur dort, weil eine Freundin
von mir als Vorband gespielt hat, aber ich
habe trotzdem schöne Erinnerungen.
Und…
- Ja.
Genau, dahinter ist noch die Mercedes-Benz
Arena.
Das ist eine große Arena, wo dann so Bands
wie Coldplay spielen, aber da war ich noch
nie.
Ich, glaube ich, auch noch nicht.
Es ist interessant, wie viele Teile in Berlin,
wo früher die Mauer stand, da ist heute,
also wurde in den letzten 30 Jahren sehr viel
gebaut.
Und so ist auch dieser Teil, an dem du jetzt
bist, ein Ort, wo es sehr viele neue Gebäude
gibt, und es wird immer noch sehr viel gebaut.
Also man muss sagen, nach 30 Jahren ist das
noch nicht zu Ende, es wird immer noch umgebaut.
Ja, während Manuel läuft, mit Rawad, werden
wir mal unsere Zuschauer begrüßen auf YouTube
und Facebook und wir wollen euch fragen, wo
ihr gerade seid.
Aus welchem Land guckt ihr zu?
Schreibt uns mal einen Kommentar.
Maria hat schon mal geschrieben und sagt Hallo
aus Polen.
Brian hat geschrieben: "Hallo aus Singapur".
Emerson ist in Kolumbien, Ega in Indonesien,
es sind viele verschiedene Orte heute.
Yusra guckt uns auf Facebook aus Marokko,
Paolo aus Anápolis in Brasilien, Kasachstan
haben wir dabei, Syrien.
So schnell geht das jetzt.
Bochum, Aserbaidschan, Japan, Jordanien.
Ich komme nicht mehr hinterher, Leute.
Taiwan, Russland, Bosnien, Vietnam, Indien.
Menschen aus der ganzen Welt gucken uns zu.
Janusz, Manuel, was sagt ihr dazu?
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Manuel, du bist schon angekommen.
Wir sind schon angekommen.
Tatsächlich geht es hier los und wir können
ja erst mal hier ein Detail zeigen.
Also hier ist eine kleine Plakette, auf der
steht: "Berliner Mauer East Side Gallery".
Dort stehen ein paar Daten, nämlich das Datum,
als die Mauer gebaut wurde und als sie gefallen
ist.
Und dann sieht man auch, dass man kurz danach,
schon ein paar Monate, nachdem die Mauer gefallen
ist, begonnen hat, hier also Kunst drauf zu
malen.
"Bemalung", das ist das Nomen des Verbes "malen".
Bemalung.
- Und…
Ja, das ist also ein Denkmal, das steht hier
noch.
Und man muss aufpassen, hier gibt es viele
Touristen und deswegen gibt es natürlich
hier auch Trickbetrüger.
Aber da es heute sehr kalt ist, denke ich,
werden wir davon niemanden antreffen.
Ja, und ich würde sagen…
Ich weiß nicht, sollen wir einfach jetzt
mal langsam vorbeigehen und ihr ruft "stopp",
wenn ihr euch ein Kunstwerk genauer anschauen
wollt?
Oder wollen wir vielleicht mal ganz kurz noch
auf die andere Seite gucken?
Also das ist vielleicht noch interessant zu
sagen: Das hier war also der Berliner Osten.
Also jetzt stehe ich im ehemaligen Ostteil
von Berlin und…
na ja, also streng genommen, hinter der Spree
beginnt dann der Westteil.
Also die Spree, der Fluss, der große Fluss
in Berlin, der ist da drüben, den werden
wir später auch noch sehen, aber ja, hier
ist also die andere Seite der Mauer.
Und man kann das hier, finde ich, sehr eindrucksvoll
sehen, sage ich mal, wie hoch die war und
wie die verlaufen ist.
Ja.
Und das ist sogar nur ein Stück der Mauer.
Es gab eigentlich eine Außenmauer und eine
Innenmauer.
Also das ist jetzt…
Stimmt.
…das äußere Stück.
Wir können vielleicht mal ein Foto einblenden,
wo man sieht, wie diese Straße, auf der du
bist, früher aussah, das war nämlich tatsächlich
einfach eine normale Straße, man konnte dort
herfahren.
Und links sieht man jetzt die Mauer, an der
du stehst, oder vielleicht von oben gesehen
noch mal.
Da sieht man diese Mauer, man… dazwischen
war einfach ein grüner Streifen und der Fluss,
der war dann eigentlich die Grenze auf der
rechten Seite.
Und es gab also auch Menschen, die versucht
haben, Berlin zu verlassen, indem sie über
das Wasser, also, geschwommen sind.
Ja, Manuel, zeig uns doch mal ein paar Kunstwerke.
Ich habe vorher ein bisschen recherchiert,
ich habe mich schlau gemacht, damit wir hier
nicht gefährliches Halbwissen verbreiten.
Und zwar…
Ja, hier sehen wir eins von Amnesty International
scheinbar, mit der Friedenstaube.
Ich finde, das ist schon mal ein schönes.
Manuel reagiert auf Kunst.
Jetzt zeigt sich, was für ein Kunstbanause
ich bin, weil ich wahrscheinlich die wirklichen
Perlen hier gar nicht erkenne, aber gut.
Schön.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich so gewesen, dass
sich damals, also schon 1989, das war ja so:
Im Sozialismus wurden die Künstler ja durch
den Staat beauftragt und bezahlt, also, meistens
zumindest.
Und plötzlich brach den Künstlern in der
DDR, nach dem Ende des Staates brachen die
ganzen Aufträge weg und sie haben dann schnell
die Zusammenarbeit gesucht.
Und es gab quasi zwei Kunst…
Künstlervereinigungen in Ostdeutschland und
Westdeutschland, die haben sich zusammengetan,
um also gemeinsame Lobby für die Künstler
zu machen in Ost und West.
Und die haben dann als erstes gemeinsames
Projekt Künstler aus ganz Deutschland und
aus der ganzen Welt eingeladen, um gemeinsam,
ja, dieses Stück der Mauer zu bemalen.
Zeig das doch mal, Manuel.
Das hier?
Ja, das…
- Dancing…
Und das rechts.
Aha, hier.
"Curriculum Vitae", da geht es um Flüchtlinge.
"Escape is a mighty method to destabilise
dominion.
Gratitude to the killed and surviving refugees".
Also hier geht es um die Erinnerung an die
Flüchtlinge aus der DDR, die du gerade ja
schon kurz erwähnt hast.
Viele Leute haben versucht, zu fliehen, aus
der DDR.
Einige haben es geschafft, einige, mehrere,
viele sind auch ums Leben gekommen.
Und darum geht es in diesem Kunstwerk.
Manuel, zeig mein Datum auf diesem, auf dieser
Mauer.
Dein Datum?
Ja, wann bist du denn nach Deutschland gekommen?
Das muss 1984 gewesen sein?
Ist das richtig?
Ja.
Ja, bravo.
Richtig.
Das ist richtig.
Ja, Janusz, du hattest das Glück, dass du
mit einer Fähre fliehen konntest, darüber
haben wir ja vor einem halben Jahr ein Video
gemacht.
Und in, ja, in Berlin war das tatsächlich
so und in Ostdeutschland, dass dort auch auf
Menschen geschossen wurde.
Also das war zu deiner Zeit schon, ja, nicht
so gefährlich, als du aus Polen geflohen
bist.
Du hattest nur Angst, dass du vielleicht zurückmusst,
dass dein Pass weggenommen wird, aber in der
DDR mussten, ja, haben viele Leute ihr Leben
verloren auch bei dem Versuch.
Das ist unvorstellbar.
Heute kann man sich solche barbarischen Handlungen
nicht mal vorstellen, ja?
Auf unbewaffnete Leute, von denen man wusste,
ganz genau wusste, die wollen nur dem scheiß
Land entfliehen, hin zu Familien sehr oft.
Und da, dass man auf die Leute hat schießen
lassen, ist einfach unverzeihlich, geschichtlich
unverzeihlich.
Das kann man nicht sühnen, ja?
Wow, zeig mal das, Manuel.
Das hier?
Ja, du sagst, Janusz, das ist heute unvorstellbar,
aber in anderen Ländern passiert das ja immer
noch, also.
Diese Brücke, die hier abgebildet ist, das
ist die Oberbaumbrücke und die ist da drüben.
Ich hoffe, dass wir das schaffen.
Also noch kann man sie…
wahrscheinlich auf dem Livestream jetzt nicht
erkennen, ich kann sie sehen.
Wir legen gleich mal einen Zahn zu, damit
wir da auch noch einen Blick von werfen können,
aber das ist diese bekannte Brücke, die trennt
die Stadtteile Kreuzberg und Friedrichshain.
Und da sieht man Menschen, die…
- Und…
…trinken.
Aha, das ist ein schönes…
das gefällt mir, das Bild.
Guck mal, das bist du, Manuel, mit einem Laptop
und darauf ein Kaffee.
Nee, das würdest du niemals machen, einen
Kaffee auf den Lap…
Das ist doch…
Ist das ein Laptop?
Das sieht aus wie ein Einkaufskorb.
Ach, der hier!
- Das ist doch ein Laptop, ja.
Aber der raucht ja, ich rauche doch nicht,
Cari.
Ach so, nee, das auch nicht.
Und ich würde auch nie, nie, nie meinen Kaffee
auf meinen Laptop stellen.
Das…
Ja.
Machst…
Das stimmt.
Ja.
Hier ist eine Frage: "Was sind diese 'purple
pipes' oder 'poles'?"
Die hat man eben gesehen.
Ich weiß das tatsächlich auch nicht.
Weißt du das?
Ja, ich kann das sagen.
Also ich weiß nicht genau, was jetzt der
spezifische Zweck ist, aber die sind immer
dafür da, um Wasser abzutransportieren.
Also ich glaube, bei Baustellen, wenn man
den Boden aushebt, also wenn man ein Loch
quasi macht, um dort ein Gebäude zu bauen,
dann trifft man auf viel Grundwasser und das
muss weg.
Und wenn man in der Nähe einen Fluss hat,
so wie wir hier die Spree haben, dann wird
das über diese Rohre in die Spree abgeleitet,
das Wasser.
Okay, da weißt du mehr als ich.
Mohamad schreibt: "Ist es dort immer so ruhig?",
Manuel?
Nein.
- Das würde ich auch gern wissen.
Ich denke, im Sommer und natürlich auch gerade,
ja, zu Zeiten, wo mehr Tourismus noch herrscht
als jetzt — Vorsicht, Rawad, es kommen Fahrräder
hinter dir — da gibt es hier natürlich
viele Touristen.
Also das ist ja eine der Hauptattraktionen
in Berlin, die man sehen muss, wenn man Berlin
besucht, ganz klar.
Ja.
Also wenn man im Sommer an diesem Ort ist
und wenn nicht Corona ist, dann ist dieser
Bürgersteig, dieser Gehweg, auf dem du jetzt
gehst, komplett voll, muss man sagen.
Dann kann man nicht einfach alleine vor dem
Bild stehen, sondern…
Oh, das ist doch ein schönes Bild.
Ein Trabi, oder?
Was ist das hier?
Ja. Janusz, kannst du uns etwas erzählen
zu diesem Auto?
Es war ein sehr ordentliches Auto, sehr fortschrittlich,
ohne Metall gebaut, die ganze Karosserie war
aus Plastik.
Dadrunter war ein kleine, kleines, kleines,
kleiner Motor, so, aber der fuhr dann, fuhr
und fuhr.
Aber das Besondere daran ist, dass es nur
dieses Auto gab in der DDR.
Ja.
Das war die…
- Nein, absolut nicht.
Es gab noch Wartburg.
Es gab noch den Wartburg und die hatten noch
irgendwas.
Auf jeden Fall, man muss schon sagen, dass
Ostbe…
Ostdeutschland als Staat war der führende
Staat in dem ganzen Ostblock.
Also wirtschaftlich ging es denen noch am
besten, und zwar immer, ja?
Ich weiß, irgendwann, aufgrund irgendeiner
Freundschaftsbekundung haben die Ostdeutschen
(den Polen) erlaubt, ohne Visum nach Ostdeutschland
zu fahren.
Und die haben das aber schnell bedauert, weil
die Polen dann quasi massenhaft eingefallen
sind und alles weggekauft haben, was es zu
kaufen gab, aber na ja.
Meine Mama und meine Oma ist (sind) mitgefahren
als Dolmetscher, deshalb weiß ich das.
Aha, das ist ja spannend.
Und meine Oma…
Und meine Oma hat auch erzählt, dass die
ostdeutschen Verkäuferinnen oft ziemlich
verärgert waren wegen diesem, wegen dieser
massenhaften Welle der…
- Einkauf.
Einkau…
…der einkaufswütigen Mitbrüder aus Polen,
ja.
Okay.
Ja, man musste jahrelang warten auch auf so
ein Auto, ne?
Also…
Ja.
War nicht einfach.
- Ja, absolut.
Ja, das stimmt auch.
Stavroula hat noch festgestellt: Das Autokennzeichen
auf dem Bild war vom 9. November 89, der Tag
des Mauerfalls.
Ist uns wieder nicht aufgefallen, das Detail.
Minh Chau möchte gerne wissen: "Was ist dein
Lieblingsbild, Manuel?"
Ehrlich gesagt weiß ich das noch nicht.
Ich habe ja noch nicht alle gesehen und entscheide
mich dann später, wenn das in Ordnung ist.
Also bis jetzt…
- Das…
Bis jetzt fand ich das mit der Friedenstaube
ganz schön.
Fandest du schön?
Oh, du bist jetzt in einem Tunnel, was ist
das da?
Ja, das passiert häufiger mal in Berlin.
In Berlin wird immer viel gebaut und als Fußgänger
und oft leider auch als Fahrradfahrer muss
man dann durch so mega enge Tunnel fahren,
das ist wirklich gefährlich.
Vorsicht, Rawad.
Rawad wäre fast jetzt hier gegen das Ding
gelaufen, aber das gehört zum Leben in der
Großstadt dazu, würde ich sagen.
Komm, wir wechseln wieder.
Verstehe. Manuel, Janusz hat mir gerade gesagt,
dass mein Mikrofon knackt, das würde ich
gerne einmal testen.
Stimmt das, dass das Mikrofon knackt?
Das muss…
das müssen die Hörer*innen und Zuschauer*innen…
Schreibt uns mal einen Kommentar und…
- …beurteilen.
Erik und Chris, die bei uns hinter den Kulissen
sitzen, können uns auch einen Kommentar schreiben.
Vielleicht hat nur Janusz dieses Problem gehört.
Ich gehe mal zurück in die Kommentare und
habe einen Kommentar von Stephen.
Er schreibt: "Ich finde es schade, dass eine
mehrspurige Straße neben der Mauer ist.
Der Gehweg sollte ausgeweitet werden, an manchen
Tagen ist es zu eng und laut."
Es ist doch so wahr, oder?
Wie kann das sein?
Es sind eins, zwei Spuren auf jeder Seite,
dann noch mal eine Spur für parkende Autos.
Und die ganzen Menschen, die sich dieses Stück
Geschichte von Berlin anschauen wollen, die
teilen sich ungefähr drei Meter auf diesem
Bürgersteig.
Was ist denn das für eine Prioritätensetzung?
Da wird übrigens grad ein Auto abgeschleppt,
auch ganz spannend.
Zeig mal.
- Guck mal.
Oder wird das da wieder hingesetzt?
Was?
- Wir wissen es nicht so genau.
Vielleicht wird es auch abgeliefert.
Sieht irgendwie so ein bisschen so aus, als
würden die das hier parken.
Na ja.
Also, immer spannend, was hier so passiert.
- Ja, das sieht gut aus.
Also, Karen schreibt: "Nein, es knackt nicht",
Ronaldo schreibt: "Sendung ohne Probleme",
Marcia schreibt: "Kein Problem mit dem Mikrofon",
und Alina schreibt: "Alles gut."
Also vielleicht hört nur Janusz das Knacken.
Tja.
- Dann würde ich sagen: Schade für Janusz,
aber gut für alle anderen.
Ja.
Manuel, diese Mauer ist ja viel länger noch
als ich dachte.
Ja, und zwar 1,3 Kilometer und damit das längste
Stück der Mauer, das noch überhaupt existiert,
und auch die längste Open-Air-Galerie der
Welt, habe ich gelesen.
Caperot schreibt: "Wie kalt ist es dort",
Manuel?
Vier Grad Celsius.
Vier Grad.
Das ist für, würdest du sagen, für Januar
in Berlin kalt oder warm?
Moderat.
Ich glaube, das…
Guck mal, das ist, glaube ich, mein neues
Lieblingsgemälde hier.
Das ist so richtig schön wild.
Oh ja, das ist sehr schön.
- Hier steht noch was: "Die Rechte an diesem
Bild gehören mir, der Geschichte, der Mauer,
der Wahrheit, Gott und allen Menschen."
Das ist wirklich schön.
Ich habe eine schöne…
- Und es ist…
…eine schöne Frage von Vladislav.
Er fragt: "Was denkt eigentlich die jüngere
Generation über die Berliner Mauer und die
Ereignisse vor der Wiedervereinigung von Deutschland?"
Manuel, da frage ich direkt mal dich, du bist
ja die jüngere Generation.
Du bist zwei Jahre vor der Wiedervereinigung
geboren, du kennst nur das, eigentlich das
gemeinsame Deutschland.
Was denkst du über diese Zeit?
Ich denke, dass das natürlich ein ziemlich
trauriges Kapitel ist unserer Geschichte und
gleichzeitig aber auch ein Teil unserer Geschichte,
der Hoffnung stimmt, denn es gibt ja noch
viele Mauern auf der Welt.
Und die Teilung Deutschlands und dann die
Wiedervereinigung hat bewiesen, dass das geht,
dass man als geteiltes Volk oder als, ja,
zwei Nationen, die sich gegenüberstehen,
auch wieder zusammenkommen kann.
Und da gibt es ja noch viele andere Länder
auf der Welt, die darauf noch die Hoffnung
haben.
Das hast du schön gesagt, Manuel.
Danke.
Hier ist übrigens die Mercedes-Benz Arena,
wo ich tatsächlich Coldplay-Tickets habe
für dieses Jahr, bin mal gespannt, ob das
stattfinden kann.
Toll, sind wir jetzt gesponsert von Mercedes?
Nein, und auch nicht von Coldplay, aber ich
dachte, ich zeige es mal, was es hier so gibt.
Wir haben einige Fragen bekommen, Manuel,
die werde ich jetzt mal vorlesen.
Andres möchte gerne wissen: "Leidet die Mauer
ab und zu unter Vandalismus?
Wer schützt die Mauer?"
Ja, absolut.
Sie leidet unter Vandalismus und natürlich
auch einfach unter dem Wetter, unter Wettereinflüssen,
denn es ist ja draußen hier.
Und deswegen gibt es einen Verein, ich glaube,
der steht hier auch irgendwo drauf, der sich
quasi darum kümmert, dass hier instand zu
halten, und auch die Kunstwerke.
Es gibt hier Kunstwerke, die quasi schon seit
1990 hier sind.
Das sind aber längst nicht mehr die originalen,
also die mussten neu gemalt werden, weil das
natürlich nicht hält über so viele Jahre.
Ja.
Die wurden tatsächlich noch mal bemalt.
Wenn wir gleich ein bekanntes Kunstwerk sehen,
kann ich das mal zeigen.
Daniele möchte wissen: "Gibt es noch Teile
der Mauer, die noch nicht bemalt wurden?"
Auf diesem Stück nicht, nee.
Da ist alles bemalt.
Schon mehrfach bemalt, aber es gibt noch ein
anderes Stück, da können wir vielleicht
in der Zukunft mal einen Livestream machen.
An der Bernauer Straße gibt es eine Gedenkstätte
und da sieht man tatsächlich noch die Originalmauer
mit der Grenze.
Oh, Manuel, du bist an einem besonderen Ort
angekommen.
Jo, und es gibt hier richtig eine Schlange,
eine Foto-Schlange.
Ich glaube, ich muss mich mal einreihen, bis
ich mich davorstellen darf, denn tatsächlich
möchten alle ein Foto machen von diesem Kunstwerk.
Aber da sich keiner hinstellt, mache ich das
jetzt einfach mal.
Und du kannst mal kurz erklären, worum es
hier geht.
Ja, dieses Kunstwerk ist der, heißt "Bruderkuss".
Es ist das Kunstwerk des russischen Malers
Dmitri Wrubel.
Wir haben ihn tatsächlich…
- Hier sieht man's.
…zufällig schon einmal interviewt in einer
Easy German Episode.
- Echt?
Ja, aber ich habe leider vergessen, in welcher
Episode, es ist aber sehr, schon vier oder
fünf Jahre her.
Und…
- Komm, wir machen mal Platz.
Ja, dieser, dieses Bild, vielleicht kann Rawad
das gleich noch mal von Weitem zeigen.
Es zeigt ein sowjetisches Ritual.
Janusz, was sehen wir dort?
Wir sehen dort zwei Staatshäupter, die…
Staatsoberhäupter.
Staatsoberhäupter, die sich einen rituellen
Brüderkuss geben.
Also wahrscheinlich ist der Breschnew nach,
aus Deutschland gekommen und Honecker hat
ihn begrüßt und die haben sich so einen
dicken Schmatzer auf die Lippen gegeben, auf
den Mund.
Und das befremdet uns heute so ein bisschen,
aber damals war das ein Ritual.
Damals war das so eine Visualisierung, dass
wir Brüder sind und im Guten und im Schlechten.
Ja, es gab richtig in der Sowjetunion ein
Zeremoniell oder ein Protokoll, wie man sich
begrüßt.
Es gab ja auch bestimmte Begrüßungen so.
Und man hat sich bei Staatsbesuchen — das
war jetzt gerade Leonid Breschnew, das russische
Staatsoberhaupt, und Erich Honecker, Staatsoberhaupt
der DDR — hat man sich so begrüßt.
Ich möchte euch noch ein Bild zeigen, dass
wir vorbereitet haben.
Und dort sieht man nämlich ganz gut auf diesem
Bild, wie der Dmitri Wrubel dieses Bild nachzeichnet.
Also er hat das 1990 im Original gemalt und
2009, also vor dreizehn Jahren, wurde diese
Mauer restauriert.
Und hier sieht man, wie er das Bild noch mal
neu nachgezeichnet, übermalt hat quasi.
Ich muss mich übrigens korrigieren: Es gibt
doch noch freie Flächen, scheinbar.
Also hier ist alles weiß, ich hätte mal
ein paar Sprühdosen mitbringen sollen, dann
hätte ich hier vielleicht ein Easy German…
- Ganz dicke Easy German.
Ja.
Genau.
Nee, weiß ich nicht, ob das hier selbst auch
schon Kunst ist oder ob das eine Vorbereitung
ist für ein weiteres…
Was steht denn da, Manuel?
- …neues Kunstwerk.
Da ist doch eine Infotafel.
Das ist nur die gleiche Plakette hier von
immer, wo draufsteht, wann die Mauer gefallen
ist, also da steht nichts.
Ja, gut, dann werden dort die nächsten Kunstwerke
vorbereitet.
Du kannst dich ja mal bewerben.
B Chris möchte wissen: "Gab es Tunnel unter
der Mauer?"
Ja, das gab es, und zwar sowohl gescheiterte
Versuche als auch erfolgreiche Versuche, nicht
so viele.
Es gibt auch einen sehr guten Film, der heißt,
glaube ich, "der Tunnel", wo man das sehen
kann, so einen dieser Fluchtversuche.
Kim möchte wissen: "Können wir mal in den
Mauerpark gehen?"
Der ist jetzt tatsächlich am anderen Ende
der Stadt, aber vielleicht machen wir das
in Zukunft mal, eine Episode aus dem Mauerpark.
Gute Idee.
Ich habe noch eine ganz tolle Frage für dich,
Manuel, von Jenny.
Sie möchte wissen: "Ist Berlin immer grau?"
Gefühlt schon, acht Monate im Jahr ungefähr,
und dann hat man vier Monate ein bisschen
Sonne.
Ich übertreibe jetzt, ja?
Ganz so schlimm ist es nicht, aber der Winter
ist schon sehr grau, muss man sagen.
Und so ein Wetter wie heute ist halt einfach
typisch, ne?
Typisch Berliner Winter, das ist so.
Muss man wissen, wenn man nach Berlin kommt,
nicht so viel Sonne.
Kannst du mal…
Rawad, kannst du mal den Himmel zeigen?
Gar nicht schlecht.
Gar nicht schlecht, es gibt Wolken.
Hier, Vladislav hat uns eine Info geschrieben:
"Leonid Breschnew war für seine Bruderküsse
in der Sowjetunion ganz bekannt.
Es gab viele Scherze darüber."
Und Jenny möchte wissen: "Gibt es keine Maskenpflicht
in Berlin?"
Nur in Innenräumen, in Bahnen, Restaurants
und so weiter, aber nicht in…
also draußen auf dem Bürgersteig.
Schaut mal, Leute, ich habe einen Trabi entdeckt.
Schön!
Da sieht man den.
- Ist das nicht toll?
Leider ist abgeschlossen, sonst dachte ich,
könnten wir eine kleine Tour machen, aber…
Natürlich.
Das ist schön, man sieht richtig, wie klein
und kompakt der war.
Und ja, hinten eine Sitzbank, da saßen dann
die Kinder drauf.
Ist doch toll, oder?
Was es hier alles gibt.
Jenny freut sich, dass du auf ihre Frage geantwortet
hast.
Jobin schreibt: "Manuel ist immer lustig."
Danke.
Nagaha schreibt…
- Ja, ich versuche, den hier aufzumachen,
aber…
Was machst du denn da?
Das ist Sachbeschädigung, Manuel.
Finger weg!
- Ich wollte…
Ich dachte, wir gucken mal unter die Haube.
Du bist mir aber einer.
Ganz schön frech.
Hier mal eine kleine Hausmitteilung.
Everett möchte wissen: "Wie oft machen Sie
einen Livestream?"
Manuel, kannst du uns diese Frage beantworten?
Ja, das kann ich sehr gerne.
Im Moment einmal im Monat, und zwar meistens
am dritten Mittwoch des Monats.
- Dritten, ja.
Schön.
Das ist unser Plan.
Dann haben wir noch ein, zwei Fragen.
Vielleicht können wir noch zwei, drei beantworten,
bevor wir gleich an unseren finalen Ort kommen.
Arnie möchte wissen: "Wer darf seine Kunst
auf der Mauer verewigen?
Jeder oder wird ausgewählt, und wenn ja,
wie und wer wählt aus?"
Ich glaube, so ganz genau wissen wir das nicht,
wer die Kunst auswählt, aber es gibt dort
einen Verein, wie Manuel gerade schon gesagt
hat, der sich um die Mauer kümmert.
Und ich schätze, dass der Verein das auch
auswählt.
Also jeder…
Manuel darf da jetzt nicht einfach malen auf
der Mauer.
Nein, definitiv nicht, das ist Künstlern
vorbehalten.
Cari, ich bin schlecht vorbereitet, wie kommen
wir denn jetzt überhaupt auf die Brücke
drauf?
Müssen wir hier…
Ich glaube, du kommst oben gar nicht drauf,
da fährt ja nur die U-Bahn, aber du kannst
unten…
- Ach ja, stimmt!
Wir sind ja schon oben quasi.
Ich dachte, wir könnten noch höher, aber
da ist nur die U-Bahn.
Was auch keinen Sinn macht, es ist ja die
U-Bahn, die müsste ja eigentlich unter…
Richtig.
Untergrund.
- Aber das war gerade schon ein sehr schönes
Bild, wie die gelbe U-Bahn über die Brücke
gefahren ist.
Ja.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie ihr jetzt dadrunter
kommt, wahrscheinlich müsst ihr jetzt zum
Wasser laufen.
Lauf doch mal da den Gehweg weiter, wo…
unter dir.
Nee, dadrunter ja nicht, wir gehen jetzt hier
über die Ampel und dann schauen wir gleich
mal, was es da hinten gibt.
Das hier ist übrigens Universal, großes…
wie sagt man?
Musiklabel.
Ja.
Und genau, also noch mal zur Orientierung:
Rechts von mir, also da hinten, hinter der
Brücke, ist Kreuzberg und in diese Richtung
ist Friedrichshain, sehr bekannt für die
vielen Clubs, Techno-Clubs und sonstige Clubs.
Party, Party.
Oh, da kommt die Polizei.
- Party, Party, Party.
Action.
Polizei gehört natürlich auch immer dazu
in Berlin.
Leute, ich zeige euch noch mal ein Bild kurz,
damit ihr seht, wo wir jetzt sind.
Manuel ist die ganze Mauer entlanggelaufen,
und hinten rechts seht ihr eine Brücke und
da ist Manuel jetzt.
Und so sah das aus 19… in den Achtzigern,
ich weiß nicht genau, wann.
Und jetzt bist du schon unter der Brücke.
Richtig, es ist sehr dunkel hier.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr überhaupt noch was
seht, aber genau.
Dieser Teil ist auch sehr bekannt, weil…
Also ich assoziiere mit dieser Brücke die
Feiernden, die tatsächlich nachts in den
Clubs sind und dann hier, also wenn man hier
samstagnachts um drei ist, in Nicht-Corona-Zeiten,
dann sind hier viele Betrunken, die nach Hause
gehen, würde ich sagen.
Ja.
Und das andere, was es hier gibt, ist ein
wunderschöner Ausblick auf die Spree.
Hier sieht man auch mal, wie weit, also wie
breit die Spree überhaupt ist.
Wow.
Und…
genau, wir haben hier letztens noch eine Bootstour
gemacht.
Letztens ist gut.
- Erinnerst du dich?
Das war im Oktober.
Ja.
Ja. Manuel, die Oberbaumbrücke wurde 1895
gebaut.
Das ist schon länger her, ne?
- Krass.
Ja.
Übrigens, ich habe noch eine lustige Geschichte
zu der East Side Gallery.
Die haben nämlich am Anfang Sponsoren gesucht
oder die haben erst mal geguckt, wer ein Partner
sein könnte.
Und die amerikanische Botschaft hat dann vorgeschlagen…
oder die haben Sponsoren gesucht und das ganze
Projekt sollte erst mal von McDonald's und
Coca-Cola gesponsert werden.
What?
- Und da… da haben dann aber die Künstler
gesagt: "Nee, das passt nicht zu unserer Kunst
und dann lieber kein Sponsoring", so ungefähr.
- Das ist ja verrückt.
So ungefähr war das.
Janusz, wie fühlst du dich?
Ja, sehr nostalgisch.
Sind ja meine Zeiten.
- Wärst du jetzt auch gerne…
auch gerne draußen mit Manuel?
Heute nicht unbedingt, aber so in vier Monaten,
ja.
Noch eine Frage von Siri: "Gibt es in Berlin
Gebäude, die vor dem Zweiten Weltkrieg gebaut
wurden?"
Definitiv, viele.
Klar.
- Manuel steht gerade auf einer Brücke, die
wurde schon vor dem, sehr weit vor dem Krieg
gebaut.
Ich wohne auch in einem Haus, das schon 127
Jahre alt ist, glaube ich, oder 117 oder so,
habe ich einen Brief vom Vermieter bekommen,
wo das mit drin stand.
Das ist auch schon sehr alt, ja.
Richtig.
Und wir wohnen auch in einem Haus, was schon
über 120 Jahre alt ist.
Also das gibt es sehr oft.
Manuel, wir kommen jetzt zu einem Ende.
Wir haben noch viele Fragen bekommen, zum
Beispiel: "Wo wart ihr, als die Mauer gefallen
ist?"
Viele Fragen zur Mauer.
Ich würde sagen, die beantworten wir in einer
anderen Episode, wo wir vielleicht noch mal
zur Bernauer Straße gehen, das ist die Gedenkstätte.
Dort gibt es viele Informationen zur Flucht
an der Mauer, zu dem Mauerfall selber, und
da können wir vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen
mehr erzählen über diesen Teil der Geschichte.
Sehr gerne.
Und wenn ihr Fragen habt, könnt ihr uns auch
immer Fragen schicken für unseren Podcast,
easygerman.fm, denn Cari und ich, wir machen
zweimal in der Woche einen Podcast und dort
beantworten wir auch immer gerne Fragen.
Also da haben wir auch ein bisschen mehr Zeit.
Absolut, so sieht es aus, easygerman.fm ist
unser Podcast.
Zum Schluss möchte ich mich noch bedanken
bei dem ganzen Team: Manuel und Rawad, unsere
rasenden Reporter, jetzt im Sonnenuntergang,
schon fast dunkel, Janusz, hier bei mir in
der Wohnung nebenan.
Und dann haben wir noch Chris und Erik, die
uns hinter den Kulissen geholfen haben.
Und wir möchten uns bedanken bei all unseren
Mitgliedern, die uns dieses Projekt ermöglichen,
die uns unterstützen, das sind unsere Patrons.
Wenn ihr auch mitmachen möchtet als Mitglied,
dann meldet euch gerne mal an, hier unten
wird jetzt der Link angemeldet (angezeigt)
und da könnt ihr ein Teil von Easy German
werden.
Ihr könnt mit uns chatten, ihr könnt Übungen
machen zu unseren Videos, ihr könnt Transkripte
bekommen zu Videos und zum Podcast und vieles
mehr und wir freuen uns darüber.
Manuel, wann werden wir wieder auf die Straße
gehen?
In einem Monat.
Und wo gehen wir…
- Stimmt das?
Das stimmt, aber wo gehen wir dann hin?
Was machen wir dann?
Ich verrate jetzt ein Geheimnis: Wir entscheiden
das immer mega spontan.
Wir haben das, glaube ich, vor zwei Tagen
entschieden, was wir heute machen, und dementsprechend
wissen wir das noch nicht, aber ihr könnt
uns ja Vorschläge schicken.
Was wollt ihr sehen in Berlin?
Und wir freuen uns und schauen uns das an.
Das fände ich gut, schreibt uns mal einen
Vorschlag.
Wir haben ja schon einige Ideen gesammelt,
wir werden noch mal zum Mauerpark gehen, wir
werden bestimmt noch mal zur Bernauer Straße
gehen.
Welche anderen Orte möchtet ihr in Berlin
sehen?
Schreibt uns einen Kommentar unter dieses
Video.
Und jetzt sage ich: Ich bedanke mich bei euch,
wir haben viele schöne Kommentare bekommen.
Danke, dass ihr zugesehen habt, und bis bald,
liebe Leute!
Bis bald.
- Wunderschönes Bild da im Hintergrund, Manuel.
Ciao!